you are the most intimidating phone  talker I've ever seen  are there any tips you can give me on  how to be like a real badass on the  phone oh you have to find out who you're  talking to if I gotta slip I'm going to  get my phone okay talking the guy who  took my girlfriend okay okay  you took my girlfriend then maybe maybe  eyebrows why why did you take my  girlfriend why'd you do that  we c64 - yeah I'm 6 4 - I'm six I'm tall  no she's six oh she's she's she's six  but - why'd you take her what I do you  what what what what hide are you I'll  tell you - no he's - to here are you  five-foot-eight me five foot eight  my guys are psycho yeah call them on  your listen you're a five foot eight  psycho you're a five foot eight psycho  give me back my girlfriend did I go yeah  you made us feel small  next time I'll just have you make me go